und jetzt das heute journal
windsurfer richter und christian sievers
guten abend je tiefer die regierung in
unser leben eingreift die massiver
unsere grundrechte betroffen sind desto
besser muss die basis für solche
entscheidungen sein müsste sie seien
tatsächlich zeigt sich das ganze vor
allem als eine reihe von verpassten
chancen
nehmen wir den incidents wert der ja
jeden tag neu sehr amtlich daherkommt
und darüber bestimmt wen wir treffen
können wie wir reisen und ob unsere
kinder die schule besuchen dürfen
wie kann es da sein dass ausgerechnet
bei dieser inzidenz selbst von denen die
sie errechnen speziell an wochenenden
und feiertagen eingeräumt wird vorsicht
nicht ganz aussagekräftig wie kann es
sein dass das robert-koch-institut auch
mehr als ein jahr nach ausbruch der
pandemie auf fragen wer sich wann wo wie
ansteckt immer wieder antworten muss das
wissen wir nicht so genau so sondern von
tina ist dem nachgegangen
hier im gesundheitsamt frankfurt
arbeiten sie seit beginn der pandemie
auf hochtouren
ständig trudeln die korona
positivmeldungen ein aus den laboren
kommen die befunde digital aus den
arztpraxen oder krankenhäusern immer
noch per fax und müssen nachträglich ins
system für das robert-koch-institut
eingegeben werden
auch in frankfurt zeigen sich nach
feiertagen und wochenenden regelmäßig
dellen bei den instanzen bei 64 lag sie
etwa einen tag nach ostermontag und
stieg dann auf 243 rauf trügerisch aber
an ihnen liege es nicht
es wird einfach nicht getestet das ist
der grund weshalb man es ja klar gesehen
dass die fallzahlen erstmal sehr schön
runter gegangen sind und dann wieder
nach oben gegangen sind zehn tage später
damit können sie im prinzip keine
solchen hygienischen maßnahmen treffen
das ist zu spät das ist veraltet
fest steht mit dem
infektionsschutzgesetz macht die
bundesregierung viele maßnahmen von der
sieben tage instituts abhängig
greift die nächtliche ausgangssperre wie
viele menschen dürfen sich treffen
können kinder zur schule gehen
grenzwerte von 100 150 und auch zahlen
die 165 kommen dann heraus für den
bundesgesundheitsminister macht die
orientierung an den instanzen auch
weiterhin sinn weil die erfahrung ist
das jedenfalls in dieser phase der
pandemie incident und intensiv
miteinander zusammenhängen intensiv
folgt der inzidenz wenn die incidents
steigt wenn die zahl der infektionen
steigt haben wir bis jetzt immer erleben
müssen dass dann auch der
behandlungsbedarf in den kliniken
gestiegen ist und auch die belastung auf
den intensivstationen
je mehr getestet wird desto höher sind
aber auch die instanzen
das bedeutet aber nicht unbedingt dass
alle corona positiven menschen einen
schweren verlauf erleben
virologin ulrike protzer spricht sich
deswegen auch für andere parameter aus
denn je nachdem welche gruppe betroffen
ist sind es die jüngeren sind es die
älteren sind des schulkinder und es
indes personen in altersheimen hat
dieser in tendenz werden natürlich für
die belastung des gesundheitssystems
eine unterschiedliche bedeutung deswegen
sollte man schon überlegen ob man nicht
zusätzliche parameter wie zum beispiel
die aufnahme in die krankenhäuser
da einfach dazu nehmen kann auch die
lage auf den intensivstationen ist
wichtig für die intensiv medizin gibt es
seit einem jahr ein eigenes register und
so hat man sich unabhängig von manchmal
trügerischen instanzen gemacht schon
über weihnachten und silvester und so
jetzt auch wieder über ostern weil da
eben jeden tag die zahlen konsequent
eingetragen werden deswegen hatten wir
eigentlich einen damit einen sehr guten
anhalt wie der infektionsverlauf sich
gestaltet wenn man über feiertage
tagelang keine daten hat befindet man
sich letztendlich in einem unbekannten
raum
im gesundheitsamt frankfurt schauen sie
in dieser phase der pandemie vor allem
auf die lage in den krankenhäusern
gerade jetzt wo auch vermehrt geimpft
werde sagt rené gottschalk sei die
inzidenz lage nicht mehr so wichtig der
freiburger professor gerd antes ist
medizin statistiker und mitbegründer des
deutschen netzwerks evidenzbasierte
medizin
guten abend herr professor genannt aus
freiburg wie gut ist denn aus ihrer
sicht die entscheidungsgrundlage für
deutschlands politiker in diesen
schweren zeiten dieses meiner sicht
weiterhin wirklich mehr als schlecht
weil wir von anfang an versäumt haben
daten systematisch zu erfassen und auch
vor allem vorher festzulegen welche
daten wirklich brauchen können sie mal
ein paar konkrete beispiele nennen wo
sie sagen da hakt da wissen wir einfach
zu wenig konkrete berufsgruppen konkrete
situation ja sie haben eine anmoderation
schon sehr richtig festgestellt dass wir
gerade bei der infektion weder wissen wo
es passiert noch was ist passiert und
vor allen dingen auch wer am meisten
betroffen ist und so banale dinge wie
zum beispiel den beruf mit zu
dokumentieren bei den positiven tests
ist von anfang an versäumt worden
und das kann man einmal durch die klären
es sind alles diese angaben gegenwärtig
ist ja ganz wie soll man sagen in die
frage ob leute die sozial prekär
untergebracht in schwierigen
wohnvierteln wohnen mehr betroffen sind
und auch diese daten könnte man mit
erfassen aber auch dass es bisher
konsequent versandt worden
wenn man im moment noch vielleicht beim
beruf was würde uns denn sozusagen als
licht aufgehen wenn wir den beruf mit
erfassen würden naja einmal müsste man
dann zb es waren ja immer die
friseurgeschäfte in der zusagen als
thema auf dem tisch aber es ist
eigentlich angemessen zum beispiel
friseur zu öffnen buch geschäfte zu
öffnen und den fotoladen gegenüber zu
schließen wenn man jetzt wüsste oder
zahnärzten zum beispiel
ganz kritischer beruf weil sie den
leuten so nahe sind wir wissen heute
nicht wie viel zahlen erst im letzten
jahr infiziert wurden und das zu wissen
wird uns wesentlich helfen maßnahmen zu
ergreifen die zum beispiel das richtige
schließen oder aber auch nicht schließen
herr professor anthes warum ist das so
schlecht gelöst was meinen sie ich kann
mir kaum vorstellen dass politiker jetzt
absichtlich auf eine bessere
datengrundlage verzichten
nein das kann ich mir auch nicht
vorstellen aber es ist wirklich so und
man glaubt dass man dort kaum an manchen
stellen
und ich glaube an einer stelle ist der
grund dass wir einfach nicht gelernt
haben mit zahlen umzugehen es fehlt auch
das vertrauen in die wissenschaft
also ich glaube die politik hat
gegenwärtig mehr vertrauen sie nicht
selbst die dinge auch ohne die
entsprechenden zahlen zu regeln und
deswegen sind diese ganzen
unterlassungssünden über die letzten
zehn elf zwölf monate sogar braucht man
nicht nur darüber zu erklären was ist
mit datenschutz
datenschutz wird manchmal sogar als
abwehrmaßnahme genutzt und begründet und
da ich bin wirklich kein feind im
gegenteil bin ein freund des
datenschutzes aber wenn wir in einer so
schwierigen lage sind wie gegenwärtig
sollten wir an vielen stellen bis an die
grenze gehen dessen was noch zu
rechtfertigen ist und nicht ganz früh
sagen
datenschutz dann lassen wir es mal
lieber und auch da gibt es eine massive
fehlentwicklung gucken moment mal nach
vorne was kann man konkret ändern es
gibt ja beispiele zum beispiel aus
großbritannien die machen das so ein
bisschen wie bei sonntagsfragen
wahlumfragen also repräsentative
stichproben nur halt mit testungen wäre
das aus ihrer sicht ein ein guter weg ja
das kann man nicht recht kopieren also
was wir auf jeden fall bräuchten ist
eigentlich drei bereiche einmal eine
bestandsaufnahme wo sind die wirklich
die herde für infektionen und da sind ja
jetzt zum schluss glaube ich zu recht
die schwierigen und gebiete zum thema
geworden
dann ist das zweite wie bewerten wir
eigentlich diese maßnahmen zb
ist es ja immer noch völlig unklar ob
die ausgangssperre oder auch andere
maßnahmen des lockdown überhaupt die
wirkung zeigen die man sich mit ihnen
erhofft und das dritte ist und das ist
von anfang an auch versäumt worden wir
brauchen eine große studie sagen wir 30
bis 50 1000 bundesbürger die über die
zeit begleitet werden und sagen wir als
beispiel alle zwei wochen eine blutprobe
geben so dass man weiß was tatsächlich
geschieht war dass das eines der ganz
großen problem ist immer noch die
dunkelziffer wir wissen nicht genau wie
viel wirklich infiziert werden
ich verstehe sie jetzt auch in diesem
gespräch so dass es ihnen gerade nicht
darum geht jetzt einfach mal simpel die
gefährlichkeit sozusagen
herunterzurechnen
aber haben sie manchmal ein bisschen
sorge dass das was sie sagen von manchen
auch missverstanden werden könnte also
nach dem motto wenn nicht klar ist da
muss ich mich auch an nichts mehr halten
ja die gefahr ist immer da und die
ordner wieder das problem mich von
leutnant oder auch von verschwörern
abzugrenzen
aber ich bin ja inzwischen ziemlich
unempfindlich geworden weil es einfach
keinen sinn macht dinge nicht zu sagen
die gesagt werden müssen nur weil sich
vielleicht von der falschen seite
wiederholt werden können also insofern
ich versteh ich genau was sie meinen
aber die sachen müssen einfach auf den
punkt kommen und wir sind weiterhin eine
schwierigen lage und wissen nicht so
genau was wir tun und das ist nicht
abzurücken
wir sehen zum beispiel am beispiel
schule ja geradezu einen einer art
glaubenskrieg kann man vielleicht sagen
die einen sagen man muss die schule
offen halten weil es sehr wichtig ist
für die kinder
die anderen sagen nein gerade schule ist
ein ganz ganz großer infektionsherd und
beide berufen sich jeweils auf studien
ziehen diese studien heran ist aus ihrer
sicht die mangelnde grundlage die
generelle mangelnde daten grundlage die
wir ja ganz offensichtlich haben auch
ein grund dafür dass es so viel streit
und zwist in der gesellschaft gibt
na ja einerseits einmal das aber
zweitens muss man auch genau hinschauen
und die meisten die es dann laut
weitergeben schauen nicht genau hin
und in frankfurt ist es gerade passiert
da hat man dann getestet
am ende der osterferien und die inzidenz
'nen unter diesen schülern die ersten
sechs klassen und die vorklassen ist
sind stark angestiegen
aber genau hinzuschauen heißt dann auch
wirklich festzustellen dass die
infektion nicht in der schule passiert
sein können weil diese tests vor dem
ersten unterricht stattfinden das heißt
sie kamen mit den infektionen aus den
ferien zurück und wenn man das dann
genau anschaut dann stellt man fest dass
schulen nicht der große treiber sind und
das wird teilweise wirklich fatal
überdramatisiert wer mehr weiß kann
besser gegen steuern wir wissen
erschreckend wenig sagt professor gerd
antes live im heute-journal herzlichen
dank nach freiburg im breisgau
ich danke auch ja hier weniger
gesicherte daten es gibt desto größer
wird der raum für alle die die sich ihre
ganz private wahrheit zusammenbasteln
desto größer weiteres in einer
gesellschaft in der sich immer mehr
menschen in ihrem individuellen
schützengraben verschanzen
zufrieden kann damit niemand sein und
die gelassene haltung vieler menschen in
südlichen ländern bei uns geht nicht
viel aber alles ist möglich
die findet in deutschland eher kein
zuhause
wir haben gern allerhöchste erwartungen
und sind schnell tief enttäuscht umso
interessanter der blick jetzt von außen
auf dieses deutschland im kampf gegen
die pandemie von dort ferber
ausgangssperre der ausblick in corona
zeiten nervt leer sind jetzt die straßen
am abend am tag gibt es demonstrationen
gegen die ausgangssperre gegen die
pandemie maßnahmen im vergleich sind das
recht milde maßnahmen im vergleich mit
frankreich zum beispiel deutschen
bisschen sehr sehr privilegiert waren
und sie realisieren vielleicht nicht
dass wir in frankreich seit wochen nicht
mehr aus dem haus dürfen ab sieben uhr
abends man darf zurzeit in frankreich
sich nicht von seiner wohnung entfernt
von mehr als zehn kilometern die
deutschen haben es gut gehabt
dennoch wirkt die politik erschöpft
die pandemie die vielen toten doch
vergleicht man deutschland mit seinen
nachbarn
so steht das große land in der mitte
europas so schlecht nicht da
das liegt vor allem an der medizinischen
versorgung am engagierten personal sagte
der risikoforscher 14 monate pandemie so
anstrengend für alle die deutsche
wirtschaft insgesamt hat es bislang noch
gut gepackt dank ihrer
exportorientierung jetzt hofft sie sogar
[Musik]
im europäischen vergleich stehen wir
recht gut da das liegt daran weil wir
sehr stark auf die industrie
konzentriert sind und nicht so tourismus
abhängig sind wie viele südeuropäischen
länder die chancen nach vorne sind gut
wenn wir jetzt zügig impfen und beim
impfen holt deutschland grad auf es
könnte ein lichtblick seien nur geht es
jetzt um im kleid und fehlende
gerechtigkeit die stimmung bleibt
gedämpft warum schickt deutschland so
also die deutschen neigen zu einem
zweckpessimismus das heißt sie
fokussieren sie sehr stark auf die
möglichen gefahren auf die problemlagen
das kann schlimmstenfalls dazu führen
dass man so insidern gerät bestenfalls
deckt das aber die schöpferkraft doch im
land funte von tüftlern ist es um
zuversicht in der pandemie grad schlecht
bestellt deutschland in der mx schleife
neil macgregor langjähriger legendärer
direktor des british museum und
vielleicht bester britischer deutschland
kenner und deutschland liebhaber stand
mal unter der skulptur des schwebenden
engels von ernst barlach einem mahnmal
für die gefallenen des ersten weltkriegs
und sagte dann diesen satz ich kenne
kein anderes land das so genau darauf
schaut was falsch lief
um es besser zu machen in der zukunft
sein soll hat den ersten nachrichten
überblick an diesem sonntag und da
bleiben wir bei der pandemie bei der
impfkampagne rückt die nächste etappe
näher
spätestens ab dem siebten juni sollen
auch die betriebsärzte eingebunden
werden
dafür sind pro woche eine halbe million
dosen vorgesehen
in der welt am sonntag äußerte
gesundheitsminister sparen die hoffnung
dass ich mit diesen angeboten mehr
menschen für das impfen gewinnen lassen
tschechien ist seit heute kein hoch
incidents gebet mehr
die bundesregierung stuft es nur noch
als normales risikogebiet ein grund sind
stark gesunkene infektionszahlen das
erleichtert den grenzverkehr denn damit
entfällt die pflicht schon bei der
einreise nach deutschland einen
negativen test vorzuweisen
ebenfalls seit heute gilt die
französische grenzregion modell nicht
mehr als virusvarianten gebiet was eine
entschärfung der quarantäne regeln
bedeutet per gesetz wollen die
spd-minister heil und scholz höhere
löhne in der altenpflege durchsetzen
der entwurf sehe vor dass tariflöhne zur
bedingung für geld von der
pflegeversicherung werden das sagte heil
der bild am sonntag
gesundheitsminister sparen von der cdu
reagierte auf den vorstoß mit dem
hinweis
ein gesetzentwurf liege bereits vor
damit solle auch der eigenanteil von
pflegebedürftigen gedeckelt werden
olaf scholz ist nun auch spitzenkandidat
der brandenburger spd für die
bundestagswahl
eine delegiertenversammlung wählte ihn
mit knapp 94 prozent auf platz eins der
landesliste der bundesfinanzminister
tritt im wahlkreis potsdam an
damit kommt es dort zum
kanzlerkandidaten duell denn auch grünen
chefin annalena baerbock bewirbt sich in
potsdam um ein direktmandat
wieder war es ein protest sonntag in
myanmar wieder soll es tote gegeben
haben laut medien kamen bei
demonstrationen mindestens fünf menschen
ums leben etliche sollen festgenommen
worden sein
insgesamt gingen landesweit tausende auf
die straße die proteste richten sich
gegen das militär das sich vor drei
monaten an die macht geputscht hatte
laut der uno sind inzwischen 30.000
menschen auf der flucht vor der gewalt
wer in den vorstandsetagen deutscher
großunternehmen starken china geschäft
ist der hütet sich peinlich genau davor
irgendetwas zur katastrophalen lage der
menschenrechte in ebendiesem china zu
sagen
die aktuellen zahlen zeigen der
chinesische markt wird für essenzielle
teile der deutschen wirtschaft immer
überlebenswichtiger und die mächtigen in
peking sind schnell beleidigt und machen
jetzt ganz unverhohlen klar je mehr
kritik desto weniger gewinn
dieses dilemma haben die deutschen nicht
allein
welche überstunden im schnittraum
hollywoods entertainment giganten machen
um der chinesischen führung bloß nicht
auf die füße zu treten sagt ulf dollar
die ganze welt spricht über die oscar
preisträgerin die in china stammende
klar
ihr film norbert land
ihrem heimatland aber totgeschwiegen der
grund ein interview von 2013
dort bezeichnete sie china als ein land
voller lügen deshalb fehlt im
chinesischen internet jeder hinweis auf
sie
wir fragen in peking nach florida und
den oscars sorry ich habe nichts davon
gehört
ich kenne ihren namen nicht sehr jung
er ist der mann der in china entscheidet
was gesehen werden darf
gleich zu beginn seiner amtszeit
erklärte präsident schiebt kunst habe
die fundamentale aufgabe dem sozialismus
zu dienen
immer mehr nutzt er die wirtschaftliche
macht um auch hollywood zu zensieren
denn im letzten jahr war china wegen der
pandemie mit rund zwei milliarden euro
umsatz der größte kino markt der welt
die lage ist einfach will chinas
regierung kritisiert wird vom größten
kinomarkt in der welt ausgeschlossen
das erhöht den druck auf hollywoods
bosse das spiel der chinesen zu spielen
hollywood schneidet filme schon einmal
für den chinesischen markt um
so geschehen bei bohemian rhapsody
der film zeichnet das leben der queen
legende freddie mercury nach in der
originalversion spielt seine
homosexualität eine wichtige rolle
es gibt eine kussszene in der
chinesischen version ist sie entfernt
die berühmte tanzszene ist komplett raus
geschnitten
in china ist homosexualität ein tabu
in der studie gemacht in hollywood
zensiert in peking analysiert james
tiger die selbstzensur hollywood
hollywood ist stolz auf seinen ruf die
macht von regierungen in frage zu
stellen
nun zu sehen wie es zulässt dass peking
immer mehr seine filme beeinflusst ist
sehr enttäuschend
chinas präsident weiß wenn er hollywood
kontrolliert kontrolliert er auch was
wir anschauen und was wir fühlen
hollywood ist immer öfter bereit
generell inhalte seiner filme zu ändern
nicht nur der filme die in china gezeigt
werden und so entscheidet chinas
diktatur was wir in der ganzen welt sehr
die plakate von ormat land waren schon
gedruckt kritische filme über amerika
liebt eigentlich chinas propaganda
kritik am eigenen land dagegen nicht nur
mit lent wird wohl nie in china gezeigt
seit dem ersten märz übrigens gelten
spezielle verhaltensregeln für chinas
schauspielerinnen und schauspieler
ganz wichtig dabei die liebe zur partei
und ihren prinzipien unser nächstes
thema heute abend der größte nationale
sportverband der welt der deutsche
fußball bund gibt zunehmend das bild
eines komplett zerstrittenen
intrigantenstadl sub um fußball scheint
es dort maximal am rande zu gehen jetzt
steht dfb präsident fritz keller wohl
vor dem aus
die landes und regionalverbände fordern
seinen rücktritt
es geht um einen unsäglichen
nazi-vergleich markus hahn guten abend
wie sehr angeschlagen ist der dfb chef
es ist wohl nur noch eine frage der zeit
bis fritz keller zurücktritt zu
eindeutig das votum gegen ihn 26 zu 9
stimmen für einen rücktritt nachdem er
seinen vize koch als freisler bezeichnet
hätte nach dem berüchtigten nazi richter
auch dem generalsekretär friedrich co
ceos wurde das vertrauen entzogen
auch er
wohl nicht mehr zu halten alles wie es
heißt zur abwendung weiteren schadens
des verbandes ob das reicht jetzt hat
das ganze markus jahn noch eine andere
dimension wenn man so will wenn keller
gehen sollte dann verliert der dfb schon
wieder einen präsidenten und da tobt im
hintergrund ein erbitterter machtkampf
können sie mal kurz erklären wer dagegen
wen sich aufgestellt hat ja interne
machtkämpfe prägen und leben den dfb
seit langem fritz keller auf der einen
seite generalsekretär kurt jooss
vizepräsident koch und schatzmeister
osnabrücker auf der anderen seite und
fritz keller hat viele unbequeme fragen
gestellt wollte aufklärung warum gleich
zwei steuerverfahren 1 auch gegen diese
drei warum so viele
staatsanwaltschaftliche ermittlungen und
warum vor allem ein beratervertrag über
360.000 euro in weniger als 24 monaten
für fragwürdige arbeit die geleistet
wurde er dieser berater soll dfb
interner nach außen getragen haben und
es gibt immer mehr hinweise darauf dass
sich vizepräsident koch und eben dieser
berater seit langem kennen
auch ist die frage nach eben kocht er
ist seit 2007 im verband er hätte mit
fritz keller dann den vierten
präsidenten schon überlebt die frage ist
ob das gerechtfertigt ist oder ob er
nicht vielleicht das zentrale problem
ist all das muss jetzt gelöst werden und
der vorstand hat dann das letzte wort da
hat man sich einigermaßen die augen
markus der dfb gilt quasi als
unregierbar und das macht natürlich
viele millionen fußball fans wütend
übrigens auch die normalen mitarbeiter
des dfb selbst gibt es denn irgendwie
eine chance aus dem ganzen rauszukommen
naja es gibt die chance dass die liga
die dfl leute die ja auch im vorstand
des dfb sitzen sagen wir wollen ein
komplett neuer anfang und das heißt auch
die anderen beiden schatzmeister
osnabrück und vizepräsident koch wird
das vertrauen entzogen und auch sie
müssten sich neu aufstellen
das heißt die führungsspitze des dfb
wäre dann komplett gesprengt und dann
ist die frage wer kommt danach aber die
liga schlussendlich hat noch ein
wörtchen mitzureden
und man hört sie wolle auch gegen koch
seien die zustände beim dfb markus haben
herzlichen dank heute abend und jetzt
nochmal mit weiterem sport dem
wirklichen sport in diesem fall
unberechenbare wind und rutschige
asphalt in der formel eins mussten die
fahrer heute schwierige verhältnisse
meistern und das ist lewis hamilton am
besten gelungen er gewann den großen
preis von portugal vor max deppen im red
bull mercedes kollege valtteri bottas
vor in portimao auf platz drei aston
martin pilot sebastian vettel kamen
dieses mal zwar problemfrei ins ziel
allerdings nur als dreizehnter und das
ist der beweis auch ein schlag ins
wasser kann erfolg bedeuten in der nacht
landete eine raumkapsel wie geplant im
golf von mexiko an bord drei männer und
eine frau
der sohn outen hatten ein halbes jahr
auf der internationalen raumstation iss
verbracht
sie waren die erste crew die regulär mit
einer space ex kapsel transportiert
wurden und damit von einem
privatunternehmen
weltweit haben millionen orthodoxe
christen heute ostern gefeiert einen
monat nach den westlichen kirchen
anders als vor einem jahr dürften die
gläubigen vielerorts wieder
gottesdienste besuchen wenn auch
meistens unter auflagen an der messe in
moskau russlands präsident putin teil
patriarch kirill sagte ostern gebe
hoffnungen dass die pandemie überwunden
werden kann
das war der sonntag im heute journal
fasst er wäre nicht komplett ohne
unseren ausblick auf die kommende erste
maiwoche von stefan micke
[Musik]
das kabinett wird am mittwoch
voraussichtlich ein sogenanntes aufhol
paket für kinder und jugendliche
verabschieden
zwei milliarden euro sollen damit
verteilt werden zum beispiel für
nachhilfeunterricht streit gab es in der
bundesregierung zuletzt um eine mögliche
100 euro einmalzahlung für bedürftige
familien
am donnerstag werden die schotten ein
neues parlament wählen
in den umfragen liegt die schottische
nationalpartei von nicolas deutschen
vorn
die wahl gilt als stimmungstest wie
viele schotten surgeons forderung nach
unabhängigkeit von großbritannien
unterstützen die kandidatenfrage hat die
spd vor längerem geklärt olaf scholz
soll eintreten
fehlt das passende programm für den
bundestagswahlkampf das wollen die
sozialdemokraten am sonntag beschließen
auf einem digitalen sonderparteitag
sie ist ein symbol für zivilcourage und
widerstand sophie scholl am sonntag wird
ihres 100 geburtstags gedacht als
mitglied der weißen rose rief sophie
scholl zum widerstand gegen das nazi
regime auf dafür wurde die 21-jährige
studentin zum tode verurteilt und
hingerichtet
[Musik]
fehlt nur noch der blick aufs wetter
hier sind die aussichten zum wochenstart
im nordosten gibt es bis zum mittag noch
schauer danach wird es bei zehn bis 17
grad freundlicher bevor im nordwesten
nachmittags wieder regen aufzieht
im süden bleibt es länger sonne danach
wird es regnerisch und windig der
dienstag sogar stürmisch dabei bleibt es
kühl
na ja da muss der meinung ein bisschen
nachlegen herzlichen dank dass sie an
diesem sonntagabend mit dabei waren
wir sehen uns wenn sie mögen auch morgen
montag wieder
wir sehen uns nicht denn morgen ist
gundula gause schöne woche
[Musik]